on devait faire un happening en fait
vous peignez quelque chose à vous faites
une performance tous les trois vigiles
est ce que vous êtes capable de peindre
avec votre nez ah oui vous pensez que
parce que j'ai le plus gros mais je peux
oui il ad'abord venez venez les ailes
faire tous les mois vous allez prendre
avec vous dans un mathieu vous avez pas
d'un nouveau show du matin
c'est bien pourtant c'est bien attention
et pourquoi l'avoir 30 secondes pour
faire bon faire une une magnifique
peinture d'accord une magnifique oeuvre
et vous jugerez chez vous après des
oeuvres de chacun attention vous avez et
vous avez vous regardé vous avez au
petit palais parmi les principales
commandes avec une chemise oui je sais
pas pour vous mais moi non mais non mais
vous ppc quoi ne payez pas à les laisser
et nora et gilles verdez a glissé pas
que ces partis en 30 secondes
essayez nom alors je vous dis essayer de
faire essayer de faire j'ai pas voilà
gilles vous avez dessiné vous nous direz
ce que dessiner et n'aura réellement
pas d'accord allez 30 secondes générales
et si les cherry on va voir après il
n'allait pas on va essayer de
reconnaître ces des boues et gilles jcj
mais je vous jure que jb bot vous avez
dans un instant ce qu'ils ont pas je
veux montrer les toiles mais il est bon
sens inné
voici
ra qu'on voit ça voici la toile dès lors
à toi ton est banal où la berd colis
c'est un bateau à bateaux sur l'eau
exactement et alors et gilles verdez est
franchement bien et bien regardez
regardez
mary est regardé comme ça lui va bien
non mais franchement on reconnaît on
reconnaît jules une silhouette une
personne c'est qui ben lui lapin gilbert
rozon moi je vous ai pas vous
gray du basket le tableau était bientôt
que tu disais pas qui c'était geoffrey
je peux l'amener chez moi oui alors
signé le vous avez et on a peut-être
trouvé un talent merci gilles anti père